Hello, everybody. I hope they are good.
Bitcoin is good for sure. What a move it
made yesterday. Check this out, guys,
okay? So, when we made the video, I
think that we were uh around here. Okay?
And I was telling you the idea that this
is still looked quite heavy. I was
expecting another drop. Okay? Then we go
we saw a new lower low here, okay? Check
this out. That's a new lower low, but
uh I was expecting price to go a bit
lower. Okay? Towards this zone here. I
mean, it's only $200 away.
$250 away. But, you know what I mean? It
hasn't been tested as a support just
yet. Check this out, okay?
You got this zone over here.
It was a resistance that was tested
twice before.
And we still haven't tested as soon as a
support. And you might say, "Okay, but
what about this zone over here?"
This spike here.
Neither, okay?
There you go. It hasn't been tested
neither. So, quite concerning that
Bitcoin didn't go all the way there.
Now, it decided to make a new lower low,
and then that's a massive short squeeze,
okay? In terms of
the daily time frame,
I'm going to be clear with you guys.
First of all, I don't like this week.
That's a very long week in the daily
time frame, okay? And secondly, remember
that we took a short from here. I took
some profits in this zone over here,
around 30,000.
And I left the rest uh of the trade in
running. That was around uh 40%, okay?
Where to? Towards this support over
here. It almost got there.
It didn't. So, you know, just for $250 I
didn't close the rest of the position.
It's okay. It happens when you trade
these things, okay? And now in the daily
time frame,
we've seen the short squeeze.
So, if we close this daily candle today
above the range lows, this here, are
range lows.
And right now it's above the range lows.
Then I'm going to close all my position,
okay? So, I'll just close the 40 the 40%
of the position whatever it closes,
okay? That's my idea because if we close
the daily candlestick above the range
lows, then there is a big possibility
that we've reclaimed the range and you
might see some more upside maybe even to
the mid range, okay? 30,500. So, that's
what I have at the moment.
I don't have any bias. Um I've always
been telling you that I just I just want
to trade what the market is going to
give me. So, if we get back inside the
range,
I'm out of the my short and I'm going to
look for other potential trades inside
the range, okay? That's what I wanted to
mention. Then,
in terms of day trading,
let's check the 4-hour time frame. What
do we have here?
This move from yesterday left us two big
weeks, okay? So, let me mark this for
you.
That's a week over there.
Okay, that's your two weeks. And then,
this other line is the 50% of the week.
Okay?
So, there you go.
Those are my levels at the moment. And
now you might be wondering, what's going
to happen crypto? Oh, by the way, you
also have even another week over here.
So, there are three weeks in the chart.
But, we're going to take these two
because they are at the opposite side of
each other. So,
uh what I think is that the both of
these weeks are going to get filled.
Why? Well, simply because this week has
hasn't been created to fill a previous
one. Here you had a week, but that was
filled with this
candle. Okay, so this week is a new week
that has to get filled at some point.
And the week to the upside, the same. If
you look at the left, it's not filling a
previous week. Okay?
I mean, you had a week here, but this
wick gets filled with this green candle,
all right? So, there are two wicks in
the chart, both of them are going to get
filled, and now we have to try to
understand
what's going to happen first, okay?
Which one is going to get filled first?
So, for that we need to go into the
1-hour time frame,
and let's see what is going on. First of
all, this pump. When was this pump
created? Let me check this out. So,
that was basically the New York session
at 3:00.
Okay? Then it goes to the New York
session. New York session closes here,
and then Asian session opens here, but
you have this large green candle that
happens between the two sessions.
Okay? During this time,
in this 2-3 hours gap, there is no
session, okay? New York is closed, and
Asia didn't open yet. So, this candle,
you cannot say that was in the Asian
session, because Asia session was not
open yet. But then from here, you can
see that Asia, the first thing that it
did was to set a stop hunt to the
upside. Boom. There you go. They left a
wick, and then they dumped price. Okay?
So, in my opinion, what Asia did here
was a stop hunt, and then a dump. So, I
would consider that Asia dumped price,
okay? If we mark the session, it would
have been something like this, okay?
That's the main way Asia did. Now, what
is London doing, guys? Well, London
is holding at the moment, okay? It's
very clearly holding at the moment.
Check that out. It's holding, okay? So,
what am I expecting for New York?
Um we still have a couple of hours for
the London session, but if it closes
inside this box over there,
I'm going to expect New York to pump.
Okay?
Something like this.
That's what I'm going to expect New York
to do, okay?
Now, if we go into the 4-hour timeframe,
is it possible that New York starts
dumping first? Okay?
Uh let me do this other one.
It starts to dump first and then it goes
for that week. Why?
Because if you remember,
we have another week over there. Okay?
That's another week that has to get
filled. So,
something like this would make sense.
Let me say it again, okay?
Give me a stop hunt. Maybe it will sweep
the lows, but
um I don't know if they want to sweep
the lows, okay? Well, anyway, let's
let's say something like this for now,
okay? It could It could extend a bit
more and sweep these lows of the London
session, okay? But, let's do it like
this. Come all the way here,
fill that week in the 4-hour timeframe.
That's quite
Well, it's it's not It's not small,
really.
Let me check this out.
This is a small really because the 50%
it's around 40 No, sorry, 29,468.
And here,
we've marked it at 29,440,
yeah. So, that would be the 50% of that
week filled. And then, you want to see a
reaction to fill the 50% of this week
that was created during the Asian
session, okay? This is what I'm
expecting for today, okay? This is for
day traders. Let's see if this plays out
and then, of course,
at some point, we need to go Sorry, like
4-hour timeframe again.
At some point,
we're going to need to go for this week
to the downside. Okay?
Um
but again, the daily candle close,
it could be a fake out, okay? It could
close above the range lows and then
tomorrow drop again below it. That would
be a fake out. It could be a fake out to
come later to this week, okay? Because I
feel that this week needs to get filled.
This support needs to get tested, all
right? But, this is what I'm basically
looking for today.
All right? That's what I'm looking for
today. If today
we see
something more aggressive
and we see a straight away a pump Sorry,
let me draw this.
We see one hour time frame, sorry.
We see a straight away
in the New York session
a pump right at the start fill the 50%
of the week and then a drop and then we
close the daily candle below the range
lows
we are good
for continuation
in the next days to the 50% of this week
and then I would keep my short from
31,400 running, okay? So, this is what
I'm expecting for today. I want to see
this 50% of the week filled.
Let's see if New York can do the job
because certainly, to be honest
it's looking prime for it, okay? Look at
London. London is holding perfectly
inside this box. And this is what I was
telling you yesterday, okay?
In London session
Where is the London session?
Uh
let me check. So, let me let me read the
what yesterday happened.
This was Asia
and then London.
Yep, I was telling you that I didn't
like to see London holding here. I
wanted to see London holding low, okay?
Because if it holds here, then it's a
possibility of a drop.
Okay? If they want to reclaim this this
this higher levels. So, London yesterday
they didn't manage to hold here.
So, they went lower.
Okay?
And then you had
the stop hunt
in New York
and the recovery of these two liquidity
pools.
Okay? You can see that they go
pretty much
to the dollar, okay? So
uh it's good it's good even if I didn't
get this one right yesterday.
Because I was expecting
Bitcoin to come
lower, okay, into this level. But even
even if you don't get that right, this
is also a tip for you guys.
It doesn't matter, okay? You're not
going to be right all the time, but what
is important is to analyze and still
what happened. Because if you are like,
"Oh,
I didn't read that well.
Um I'm going to go and look at what
happened now." No, you have to check and
try to understand what happened
yesterday because that's going to give
you experience for the next setups in
the future, okay? So, for example,
taking that what happened yesterday,
hopefully the next time that I see a
similar pattern,
that is basically
just we are learning here together. We
see
Asia
dumping.
And then
London, it seems that it starts to hold
off up here.
But you want to see then London to drop.
Okay? That's what happened here, 2:00.
London Well, New York opens here. Then
New York sets the stop hunt.
And the recovery, okay? So, that's what
you want to see also the next times cuz
then you might find a pattern, okay?
Now, for today,
something like this what I'm looking,
okay? You got the week in this session,
London holding here. We only have
a couple of hours left, so I'm expecting
London to hold in the inside this box.
And then the New York session, how can
you trade this, okay? There are two ways
to trade this. First of all,
the original idea is to favor the
direction today in the New York session
towards the 50% of this week, okay? So,
what could happen? The two scenarios is
that they pump it straight away here.
And then they dump. Okay? That's one a
scenario. And the other scenario is the
first they set a stop hunt and then they
come here again.
All right? So, how can you trade this?
Well, I'm going to tell you what I'm
going to do. Again, it's not financial
advice. You can do what you want. I'm
going to wait for London to close. Well,
sorry, for New York to open because
London really closes later, around here.
But, I draw my sessions like this
because then that's when New York opens
and takes all the protagonism.
So, the way that I'm going to trade this
today
is to wait for New York session to open.
I'm going to open a trade
a long, okay? And I'm going to put
another limit order
here, okay?
In case we see a sweep of the lows and
then a bounce, okay? And the stop loss
below this liquidity pool. Why? Because
it's also likely that the stop that the
sweep of the lows comes all the way to
fill this liquidity pool over here.
Okay? But, if they drop lower than this,
then, you know, we're going to come into
this one. All right? So, that's where
I'm going to trade it. I would be maybe
a position here,
another position
around here, and the stop loss around
here.
Okay? And the take profits would be one
here
and another one
here. That's what I'm going to trade
today. Let's see if it plays out or not.
Pretty clear, guys. Uh I think I I I
think I've been pretty clear. I'm not
telling you it's going to go up and
down. I'm just telling you that we have
two weeks today
I'm favoring the wick to the upside to
get filled. But,
getting inside the range lows with a
wick to the downside,
I don't really like it. So,
um I'll probably analyze the chart right
before the daily candle close, maybe an
hour before the daily candle close,
because if we close above the range
lows,
I'm going to go into lower time frame
because, again,
I'm not convinced that we're going to
be, you know, inside the range here
living this week over here. It doesn't
make much sense, so I still don't know
what to do.
Original idea is to close the trade if
we close above the range lows below
again.
I'm not that convinced. Check out that
week, guys.
It's a very long week. How many dollars?
Come on. It's like a $300 week, right?
Yeah, it's around $300 week.
So, I don't know, guys. I'm going to
wait and see what you guys do today.
Okay?
And then around the daily candle close
time, I'll post a tweet and I'll mention
what my plan is, okay? If I'm
I'm very clear, okay? I'm going to tell
you very quickly now. If I see the daily
candle close below the range lows again,
then so that would be
the daily candle close below 29,533
but or 25, then
the trade from here, the short,
is still running.
And if we close above the range lows,
then I'm going to I'm going to have to
go again through the chart, lower time
frame also,
and
make a decision, okay? And then I'll
share it with you guys.
If I close the total trade here,
the 40% of the position, or if I risk it
and I still think that it's going to
come all the way here, okay? So, tonight
stay tuned on Twitter
cuz I'll mention that around the daily
candle close.
It could be Could this be a deviation?
It could totally be a deviation, so
um these are the type of things I have
to try to think today what's better for
me the risk management. So, that's
pretty much everything that I have for
you.
You have here this day trade possibility
towards the 50% of this week, okay? This
would be a nice
1 and 1/2% move. Even if you catch from
here almost a 2% move, okay? So, that
would be a nice trade for today if that
plays out. And
also very important the daily candle
close tonight, okay? So, that's pretty
much everything, guys. Thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon.